in 1996 I was commissioned by the
Guggenheim Museum to execute a large
body of work called uses of evidence it
was a cube a very one large cube at that
each site had a window in order for the
spectators to view the interior of the
structure the exterior of the structure
was a collage of Africa and Africans as
portrayed in the Western media and
literature they looked through the
windows revealed a sharp contrast within
the cubes are tranquil civilised
domestic images of African family
members friends and Nigerian
professionals ranging from writers poets
fashion designers etc the thing is both
the exterior and the interior images are
quite true but the images captured by
Western media
overwhelmingly depict Africans as
basically primitive at best or barely
distinguishable from the African animals
not much has changed I'm afraid since
1996 when I as a cuter this work I began
my professional photography practice in
1994 but my passion and enthusiasm for
photography goes back to childhood when
my parents arranged for us to be
photographed by a professional
photographer on almost a monthly basis
it was also an opportunity for my
siblings to dress up in our light chest
gear made by our tailor later when I was
in boarding school my friends and I
bought polaroid cameras and then I began
to experiment with self potential or
what I will call proto selfie or two
portraits covergirl 1994 was my first
major work that was critically
well-received
in the US and Europe and quite instantly
became a part of the school anthologies
at universities and colleges with the
covergirl series I wanted to reimagine
the magazine cover with imagery totally
unexpected yet
profoundly reasonable the covergirl
series proposed a different way the
African can be represented in a more
complex manner like covergirl the
sartorial ality series is made up of
self portraits it is an ongoing body of
work started in 2010 in each image I
married disparate costumes from wildly
diverse traditions countries and time
frames and in mixing errors cultures I
was able to bring harmony as well to
their seemingly irreconcilable
differences this differences became a
source of inspired artistic celebration
for
example in cetera Anarchy number four I
mixed a Buddha heart inspired by the
traditional Eton Oxford College Boat
Race with a green Afghan traditional
coat and an American Boras card shirt a
quarter clutch that works in citerior
unlucky number five I wore a macaroni
wig inspired by 18th century macaroni
headgear from England
this was paired with a British Norfolk
jacket Yoruba Nigerian trousers and him
probably said african zulu fighting
stick all harmoniously coexist on one
body and with satriale anarchy
i began to invest more into the
organization of my pictures I also began
to investigate the vast possibilities of
color its emotional values psychological
impulse poetic allure and the boundless
capacity beyond the realm of meaning and
logic now entered Nollywood in october
of 2014 I returned to Lagos Nigeria
after over three decades aware and took
photographs of 64 Nollywood
personalities I captured a cross-section
of the industry as well as the next
generation of rising stars Nollywood is
the first time that you have a school of
African filmmakers truly truly
profoundly in charge of telling African
stories in their varied movies from
romantic movies horror film
gangster movies - action movies 1 seized
Nigerians portrayed with many layers of
complicities or the Nigerian or Niger
archetypes if you allow our there from
the divers the Shakira the Coquet the
gangsters the rich the corrupt
politicians the whole they pimp all in
their swagger and of course you have the
low lives and you lose us - or vividly
portrays Nollywood is Africa's mirror by
excellent typically I direct all of my
portraits from the way my subject
conducts his or her head the way the
neck is tilted the expression of the
fingers the gestures of the hands to the
gaze and overall bearing and countenance
let me describe somebody photographs to
you Genevieve in Nanji she is the
reigning queen of Nollywood here I was
quoting from the grand iconic African
cultures of the Nile Valley
civilizations namely Egypt Sudan and
Ethiopia so as to imbue her will
instantly pharaonic calm grandeur
Tiwa agile I said is the Grand Dom of
Nollywood every aspect of her being
commands attention so I pulls her with
her back to the audience her face turned
to me meet us with a redoubtable gaze
she doesn't need to seek our approval
she's all that sadek debar there was an
unspoken authoritarian and imperial
Baron that Sally dhaba exudes a permit
in head
in this portrait he's simply sat and
allowed his massive massive nay drunk
after to signal his status but an
accomplishment
Belinda ever Belinda earth has portrait
allowed me to indulge my passion for
color dressed in a long fitted blue
dress that emphasized her curves seated
on a posted green velvet bench I gamely
employed the multicolored carpet and a
bourbon color to in order to evoke the
splendor of the multicolored painted
bunting bird everything was designed to
humanize the figure of Belinda within
the frame moon Alissa Chindi is shall we
say the epitome of deluxe existence and
lifestyle her picture or portrait pretty
much speaks for herself
Alex a Kubo is a sharp study in
simplified elegance and dignity and
harmony in blue and white as well
a yin and we aware is a Nollywood
matinee idol there is a whiff of the
awake about him and that gives him an
enchanting edge that's what I felt when
I designed and organized the portrait
now Nollywood is a new face of Africa it
is modern postmodern meta modern bold
sexy shrewd and with a contagious
attitude what culture as the finale of
the project I assembled the Nollywood
stars into a group brand portrait of 64
subjects called the school of Nollywood
which was inspired by Raphael's School
of Athens that was done circle 15 or 9
it is at the buttock on this brand group
portrait it's the exact same size as
Raphael's school of art ends
it measures roughly 27 feet width by 16
and a half feet height Nollywood also
exemplifies a type of modernity never
before seen in Africa think of it there
has never been anything so indicators
with such iconic optics to come out of
Africa since the Nile Valley
civilizations of Egypt Sudan Ethiopia
outside of Nollywood the image of Africa
remains frozen in the old National
Geographic mode and safari perspective
but as Africans continue to step and see
themselves portrayed by Nollywood in
their varied and fantastic complexities
there will in turn propagate and
perpetuate the positive image of
themselves this is what Hollywood did
and continues to do for the West as
shocking as this may be it is almost a
taboo in the art world to show Africans
in a modern framework that is to say as
polished dry-cleaned manicured pedicured
and carved
part of my job is to keep beautifying
Africa for the world one portrait at a
time thank you
[Applause]
[Music]